pendant deux jours ils vont confronter
leurs méthodologies et leur expertise
ces scientifiques spécialistes des
médias venus présenter leurs travaux sur
l'histoire des médias vont apporter un
autre regard sur le sujet nous sommes
aujourd'hui tous s'accordaient pour le
dire pétri nourri de culture médiatique
cette culture médiatique elle vient de
loin et précise est beau c'est ce que
nous étudions va faire le point sur la
recherche sur nos méthodes sur nos
problématiques sur les perspectives
d'avenir de la recherche alors que cette
recherche est beaucoup développée depuis
une vingtaine d'années presse écrite
radio télévision ou internet tous les
formats sont développées des formats
mais aussi des questions sur la place du
journaliste celle du lectorat ou encore
l' approche du genre dans les médias
l'arrivée d'internet est une révolution
qui a la même dimension que celle de
l'imprimerie à la fin du xvème siècle
d'immenses conséquences
il est normal que du même coup on soit
désemparés l'histoire des médias peut
aider en rappelant ce que la longue
durée réinjectant de la lenteur dans la
réflexion et dans les comportements
l'histoire des médias peut aider je
crois les citoyens à se comporter de
façon plus lucide et plus efficace de
vin devant internet qui désormais envahi
nos vies
l'événement organisé en collaboration
avec cinq autres laboratoires de
recherche francilien devrait revoir le
jour d'ici deux ans jusqu'à demain soir
de nombreuses tables rondes seront
organisées de l'archéologie à l'histoire
du jeu vidéo
une manière de comprendre et anticiper
l'avenir des médias
en étudiant leur histoire